Speaker 1: All right, this you really
have to see to believe I'm going to play
video for you today of really a servant
serving his master. That's really what this is,
and the servant is a sitting U.S. senator and
the master is a Fox News propagandist. I'm
talking about Ted Cruz and Tucker Carlson
if you haven't been following this story.
It is really incredible what this says about
the current state of political affairs, the
current state of society in the Republican Party.
Wednesday, last Wednesday, we were, you know,
it was the anniversary of January. It was
the eve of the anniversary of January 6th,
and in a Senate hearing, Ted Cruz said we were
approaching the anniversary of a violent terrorist
attack on the Capitol. And a lot of people on the
right didn't like Ted Cruz, calling what happened
on January six, 2021, a terrorist attack. And
Tucker Carlson didn't like it. And apparently,
Tucker Carlson and Ted Cruz started texting about
it. And Ted Cruz ended up appearing on the Tucker
Carlson program to apologize. I am going to
play for you, a sitting U.S. senator, having
to go on and do a mayor culpa to the person who
is really in charge. Apparently, Tucker Carlson,
and this shouldn't surprise us. Hannity was giving
Trump advice and in contact with Trump, telling
him what to do. What does it say? What does it say
when a Republican senator answers to a right wing
media propagandist? Let's take a look at this.
Speaker 3: So we played this tape for you last
night. We were surprised by it. We preface this
by saying Every conservative she is Ted Cruz,
because he's one of the smartest and most
articulate people in the Congress, and he's
conservative. But he referred publicly to
what happened on January six. This quote
a violent terror attack. Here it is. We are
approaching a solemn anniversary this week,
and it is an anniversary of a violent
terrorist attack on the Capitol,
where we saw the men and women of law enforcement
demonstrate incredible courage, incredible bravery
risked their lives to defend the men
and women who serve in this Capitol.
Speaker 1: Really not controversial. Now,
many will focus on none of them were charged
with terrorism. It's very common that people
aren't charged with literally the thing that we
colloquially say they did. There's still a debate,
is it? Or isn't it terrorism? But it's really not
a big deal what he said and look at Tucker's
concerned face. And Ted Cruz has been a bad boy
and he's going to have to apologize.
Speaker 3: Senator Cruz was game enough
to come on tonight. We appreciate that
he joins us now. Senator, thanks so much
for coming on. So I guess what I mean, there
are a lot of dumb people in the Congress.
You're not one of them. I think you're smarter
than I am, and you never use words carelessly.
And yet you called this a terror attack when by no
definition was it a terror attack. That's a lie.
You told that lie on purpose. And I'm wondering
why you did? Well, Tucker, thank you for having
me on when you aired your episode last night,
I sent you a text shortly thereafter and said,
Listen, I'd like to go on because sir,
Speaker 1: I'd like to apologize. Pretty, please.
Speaker 3: I phrased things yesterday, it was
sloppy and it was frankly dumb. I don't buy
that. Well, I don't buy that for a look. I'm the
Speaker 1: teacher. That's not a good enough
apology. Little Ted. The teacher
is going to demand a better apology
Speaker 3: from you a long time since before
you went to the Senate, you were a Supreme
Court contender. You take words as seriously
as any man who's ever served in the Senate
and every word you repeated that phrase.
Speaker 1: I, by the way, I imagine Ted Cruz
on the Supreme Court. That's a horror movie.
Speaker 3: Do not believe that you use that
accidentally and stop it. So Tucker, as a result
of my sloppy phrasing, it's caused a lot of people
to misunderstand what I meant. Let me tell you
what I meant to say. What I was referring to
are the limited number of people who engaged in
violent attacks against police officers. And I
think you and I both agree that if you assault
a police officer, you should go to jail.
That's who I was talking about, and the reason
the phrasing was sloppy is I have talked dozens,
if not hundreds of times. I've drawn a
distinction. I wasn't saying that the thousand,
Speaker 1: this is so pathetic. If you watch
this and you go, Who has the power here?
Is it the U.S. senator or is it the fox
propagandist? It's obviously the fox propagandist
Speaker 3: is a peaceful. Protesters supporting
Donald Trump are somehow terrorists. I wasn't
saying the millions of patriots across the
country supporting President Trump are terrorists,
and that's what a lot of people have misunderstood
that. Wait a second. But even you have a hold on
what you just said doesn't make sense. So if
somebody assaults a cop, he should be charged
and go to jail. I couldn't agree more. We
have said that for years, but that person
still not a terrorist. How many people have been
charged with terrorism? On January 6th? Look, why
don't you use that word? You're playing into the
other side's characterization that is Joe Kent.
Speaker 1: Ted Cruz has been a bad bad boy.
Speaker 3: Just explained, allows them to define
an entire population as foreign combatants. And
you know that. So why did you do it? So, Tucker,
let me answer you directly. The reason I use that
word for a decade, I have referred to people who
violently assault police officers as terrorists.
I've done so over and over and over again. If
you look at all the assaults we've seen across
the country, I've called that terrorism over
and over again. That being said, Tucker, I agree
with you. It was a mistake to say that yesterday,
and I know you just said which I've been bad.
Speaker 1: I've apologized three times
Speaker 3: already, please. We've now had a year
of Democrats and the media twisting words and
trying to say that all of us are terrorists trying
to say, You're a terrorist, I'm a terrorist.
Speaker 1: And so I talk about a red herring, huh?
Speaker 3: Like people who who assault cops and
I will stand up and defend cops. And the reason
I use that word is that's the word I've always
used for people that violently attack cops. But
in this context, I get why people were angry
because we've had a year of the corrupt corporate
media and Democrats claiming anyone who objected
to the election fraud and, by the way, remember
what was happening during the break. Can I just
ask that you work in this? I just, I guess I just
don't believe you. And I mean, not with respect,
because I have such respect for you.
Speaker 1: You're so great that
this is too stupid for me to accept
Speaker 3: Kuti and your precision,
and I've seen it on display. I've covered
you as a reporter. I know how you speak and
you have sat there for a year and watched
people use language to distort the venue.
Speaker 1: It goes on from here, you can
find the entire thing online. What does it
say about society that Ted? Cruise answers to
the right wing media propagandist of the day,
obviously are elected officials should answer
to us the people. We're the ones who elect them.
That's not what's going on here. Ted Cruz is not.
Tucker Carlson is not a constituent of Ted Cruz.
This is really an indication of the power
dynamics, and Ted Cruz sort of gets to
use the term colloquially. Ted Cruz gets
cooked by everybody because remember, Trump
called Ted Cruz's wife ugly, and then Ted Cruz
came out and said, Trump's great, I support
Trump. I love Trump, Trump, Trump, Trump, and then
now here he is doing his. Could I have some more
porridge, please? Totally subservient, totally
subservient to Tucker Carlson. Really interesting,
instructive example of who is actually
holding the power in these dynamics right now